the Trump administration will try to
sell a sweeping budget plan to Congress
today that includes big cuts to Medicare
and food stamps and an increase in
defense spending but that message is
still drowned out by the up war over
abuse allegations against a former
senior White House aide president
Trump's press secretary read a statement
yesterday condemning domestic violence
she said it was dictated by the
president who has made other statements
praising his former staff secretary Rob
Porter or to resign nearly a week ago
but there are still unanswered questions
today about what the administration knew
about his alleged abuse of his two
ex-wives major Garrett is at the White
House with the latest on the story major
good morning good morning the White
House remained in a state of turmoil as
continued internal speculation was rife
about the future and job security of
White House chief of staff John Kelly
one other thing basic White House
explanations about the timeline and
events about Rob Porter's dismissal
still remain in conflict mr. president
do you have a vetting problem
president Trump ignored questions Monday
surrounding the resignation of his
former aide Rob Porter who he appeared
to defend last Friday he says he's
innocent and I think you have to
remember that Porter's first wife Colby
Holderness disputed Porter's innocence
in the Washington Post writing
living in constant fear of Rob's anger
chipped away at my independence and
sense of self-worth I'm very close to
Hope Hicks and I don't worry about her
in that in that respect Holderness also
responded to White House councilor
Kellyanne Conway who on Sunday was asked
about communications director hope Hicks
his reported relationship with Porter
I've rarely met somebody so strong with
such actual excellent instincts and
loyalty and smarts Holderness disputed
Conway's characterization writing her
statement implies that those who have
been in abusive relationships are not
strong I beg to differ the president
supports victims of domestic violence
mixed White House messages on domestic
abuse are taking a toll on Republicans
according to Arizona Senator Jeff Flake
the political fallout I think is
significant and questions remain about
the timeline of Porter's departure there
are things we
could have done better the White House
claimed that a photo of Porter's first
wife's bruised face forced his
resignation
it took chief of staff John Kelly about
12 hours to reverse his public support
for Porter White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders would not explain the
delay we learned of the extent of the
situation involving Rob Porter last
Tuesday evening and within 24 hours his
resignation had been accepted and
announced adding to the confusion is a
conversation the White House said Kelley
had less than 40 minutes after the Daily
Mail story which first exposed these
abuse allegations was published the
nature of that conversation remains a
mystery as does how much the White House
Counsel done began shared with Kelly
about these underlying abuse allegations
in their relationship to Porter's
pursuit of a full security clearance
John Thank You major still a lot of
questions